the European School of Management and
Technology in Berlin trains its students
to be managers current students include
abet aborting from Ghana mighty dead
novel from Zimbabwe and cartee so say so
let's say from Lesotho
katisa see so let's say is not a big fan
of receptions but this one was organized
by the Kofi Annan Business School
Foundation which provides his fellowship
to study so attending is important for
applicants with great potential the
foundation covers the management schools
tuition of twenty five thousand euros
and their living expenses later the
students will apply the skills they
learn here in their home countries but
right now it's small talk over drinks
and hors d'oeuvres and in the end
katti so comes around I think it's good
for networking so yes on that note I
think I can like it back in academic
life
katti so gets some individual career
training part of that is practicing a
job interview why should we hire you
I can work we beyond what I'm capable of
I it's really consumed knowledge in in a
faster rate I think I've heard his
answer thirty five times so far in a
simulated job interview the instructor
shows katissa where he goes wrong in
reality he's pretty good at promoting
himself this summer he'll start an
internship with a Berlin startup company
in the financial industry it's a big
step for the former mathematic student I
never thought I'd be a manager but now I
can think of myself as a manager and
where I can actually work with people
try to see the bigger picture than my
own job at the desk
Martita and level of zimbabwe will
complete a two year course of studies at
the es MT in the summer but today she's
starting something new a consulting
project
new ideas are needed for a free labs a
company that operates 40 technology and
innovation centers across Africa Martita
has ambitious goals myself and the team
would be able to come up with a solid
impact assessment framework that would
also be implementable and not just nice
and and you know stowed away in a
cabinet somewhere but something that's
something that's really going to be used
that's what I'm doing like to achieve
and to learn from as well the first
meeting takes place online so Matilda
can enjoy the atmosphere of a cafe
that's the idea anyway but there's a
technical problem the internet
connection isn't stable first-year
management students and their days on
the ESM T campus little variety for
Albert aborting of Ghana just for fun
she and a fellow student calculate how
long it would take to walk from
Alberta's home city Accra to Berlin
making these if I'm not in class I'm
doing good work that's basically how my
life in Berlin has become is on weekends
- is more catching up trying to fill in
the gaps so me it's at school school
school so far the probability that I
would need an lovoo is meanwhile engaged
in her online business conference that
mobile office has moved to the shared
kitchen in her dormitory the internet
connection is working a real manager is
good at improvising it's not easy to
break machida stride
katisa see so let's a is fascinated by
many things in Berlin for example the
efficiency of public transportation
everything seems to function more
smoothly than in his home country
Lesotho he says it's because the Germans
are good at concentrating focused the
yes and I think that focus I need to
adopt to it because I have seen it
produces the best results there are some
things in Germany that Katti so hasn't
got used to even after months it's
actually I opening for me to see that
these are common cars in some places you
know this is a kind of car that when
you're at home you only see them on TVs
on shows where any wisedom on TV all
this this this new brand of car German
made this like this or you look at it
specifications in a magazine you know on
the Internet
but here you just go through around a
corner and you find them three of them
parked on the same street you're like
wow Machida and Alberta visit the studio
of the Berlin artist Christian Alva he's
invited the ESM T students to take part
in a workshop he also donates some of
the proceeds of his art to the Kofi
Annan foundation I've always been doing
like a lot of projects with integration
with refugees with developing other
countries now the students have a chance
to be visually creative
what picture of Africa would fulfill
Alberta's wishes it would look green
she's wise it would be just what
Italians are homely cami and nice people
were friendly so I'm just looking at all
colors coming together to just form like
a really nice thing Alberta Boateng
Martita and Levu and catty so say so
let's see three students in Berlin who
want to help make that vibrant picture
of Africa become reality